merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre des armées les Ukrainiens
souffrent zanchant y vachant comme on
dit dans la région pour leur liberté et
pour la nôtre je le disais ici le 24
février 22 au matin la guerre d'Ukraine
c'est la confrontation de deux modèles
entre Atlantique et Méditerranée entre
Baltique et mer Noire sur ces terres
européennes qui nous ont vu nous
déchirer pendant des siècles de guerre
de migration déjà en tout sens de choc
culturel et religieux lequel de ces deux
modèles est en mesure de faire l'unité
l'impérialisme l'autocratie simpliste la
loi du plus fort non pour nous
démocrates européens c'est uni dans la
diversité et même uni dans nos
différences et nos divergences que nous
pourrons affronter le 21e
siècle pour nous démocrates européens
les relations économiques ce sont les
fonds de convergence et de solidarité
pas le chantage au gaz pour nous la
diversité des langues est aussi
indispensable à l'humanisme et à la
démocratie que la biodiversité à la
planète pour nous la Mobil c'est
erasmous pas le nettoyage ethnique en
Crimée et dans le donbas pour nous
démocrates européens la démocratie exige
qu'on la défende lorsqu'elle est
agressées bien et l'Ukraine fait partie
de la famille des démocraties
européennes absolument aujourd'hui la
situation militaire semble stable et la
fatigue supposée des Ukrainiens n'est
que l'une des multiples narrations de la
guerre de désinformation russe qui fait
rage y compris en France cette longue
bataille défensive nous pouvons et nous
devrons l'emporter avec ou sans les
États-Unis car elle est d'abord et avant
tout la nôtre et nous sommes et nous
serons de plus en plus seuls en face de
notre destin et celui des enfants de nos
petits-enfants pour citer voi vavel sur
l'Union européenne c'est bien la patrie
de nos patries qui est en danger
monsieur le ministre à l'heure où nos
livraisons marquent le pas comment notre
pays se prépare-t-il à affronter ce défi
militaire et industriel de la défense de
nos démocratie quelle échéance à 3
semaines à 3 mois à 3 ans je vous
remercie